You picked up the tesseract breaking reality
i want you to help us fix it not my forte
pretend your life depends on it i'm gonna get
a snack this wednesday i am the god of mischief
it is adorable that you think you could manipulate
me i was just standing up to make a point i'm
sorry go ahead my baby is meaningful now okay
we'll stay seated i'll do what i want to do
i'm agent mobius by the way how long have you
been here i don't know it's hard to say you know
time passes differently here in the tva what does
that mean you'll catch up this is the first time
for me in the marvel universe they first spoke
to me about iron man and captain america and even
hulk i was like well you know i don't know i'm
just kidding i need your unique loki perspective
tom would take us through the world and the
different movies it was amazing because he just
had all this information in his head we called
them the loki lectures i ended up just sort of
writing down some of the stuff he said and i
think that even worked its way sometimes into
dialogue i was full of enthusiasm and passion and
excitement i really like the whole look the sets
and the costumes you know let that do the heavy
lifting
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
loki episode 2 trailer video
we're burdened
with glorious footage so if you're brand new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos i will be doing videos for all the episodes
this season we're doing a disney plus giveaway for
memberships all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and just leave your favorite easter egg
so far in the comments but careful for spoilers
for everything that happened during episode 1 if
you have not seen the episode yet but the events
of episode 2 pick up just after this moment where
owen wilson's mobius has offered this variant loki
1130 a job working for the tva because not only do
they need his help because who better to catch a
loki than another loki but also because he senses
that this loki is capable of being a good person
that was why he was grilling him so hard asking
him if he enjoyed hurting people he was trying
to get him to admit that he didn't like hurting
people which he did by the end of the episode when
he broke so moebius is just banking that he can do
the same thing that loki 616 did redeeming himself
becoming a good character eventually and as they
explained also kind of wrapped up in this is the
idea that technically he cannot go back to where
he came from during the events of avengers end
game in 2012. so his only other option here is to
be erased from the timeline essentially it's work
for them or die not much of a choice there the
reason why he can't go back if it wasn't clear
is because of how he exists as a variant right
now in this moment if they were to reset things
with one of their devices the time reset devices
back in avengers end game before he steals the
tesseract resetting the timeline to what it should
have been essentially this version of loki would
be erased in the original loki 616 loki would just
continue on his normal timeline that was a real
cool 616 easter egg but a lot of you also asked
the question you know mcu technically supposed to
exist in a separate universe the earth 1999 999
the 616 marvel universe is the main universe of
the comics so when they started making the movies
like during the first iron man movie because they
changed the plot of his origin story so much and
all the movies changed the plots of their story
so much they just decided to say that all this
infinity saga stuff is happening in an alternate
universe but what they meant by loki 616 was
that he was the main loki so if it feels like a
continuity error even though it kind of is you do
understand now what they meant to say like he was
the main loki in the mcu this is now a different
loki if they reset everything with the time reset
device he would never have come into existence
that happened the second he portaled away with the
time stone creating a nexus event per their big
explainer that big animated movie on the history
of the tva and the time keepers so that's why
when he hit rock bottom in episode 1 he admits i
simply can't go back can i the red line that
they keep referring to at the different crime
scenes in the episode is when things approach
a nexus event once you go past the red line a
nexus event happens in a fully alternate reality
is born it's the whole reason why the time keepers
created the tva to prevent these nexus events
i did mention in my episode one video during
that big sequence that this timekeeper's face
kind of looked like king the conqueror's face
or one of his faces he has many different faces
that he wears across the timeline i will talk
more about kang in a new video this week because
there's all these sinister overtones to what the
timekeepers are doing forcing all of reality in
the multiverse into this single sacred timeline
deciding for everyone in existence what is sacred
and what is not sacred we'll learn more about that
we'll get more clues as loki goes around on the
different missions chasing down these alternate
loki's of himself blade runner style but there's
a ton more footage from episode two in these
trailers so you see mobius and loki sit down for
another josta soda that old pepsi energy drink
that went out of circulation a long time ago he's
still kind of giving loki the business like he
gives him the tva jacket labeling him as a variant
i wonder if they'll be selling those as merch too
but also while he continues to explain more about
the time variance authority and what they do
and what mobius himself is doing chasing down
this very dangerous version of loki that's going
around killing all their minutemen he's also
still taking loki to task on all his mischief
you have that funny scene where loki's like i have
never done anything wrong ever in my life what are
you talking about and there's another call back
to lady loki or the person that we think that
they're chasing down lady loki when owen wilson
says he's watched loki literally stab people
in the back betraying them 50 times like at the
beginning of episode 1 when they're investigating
that crime scene in ancient france the very same
hunter who winds up getting killed later in the
episode by lady loki in oklahoma says the bodies
of the minutemen have stab wounds all over them
consistent with the other recent killings that
was meant to foreshadow the reveal that it was
another loki that they were going after because
daggers are loki's trademark weapon there's also
that footage of him during episode 2 where owen
wilson is handing him his daggers like don't i get
a weapon and he hands him the daggers like oh this
is so awesome before that new main hunter hunter
b-15 takes them away and is like hell no you don't
get a weapon but then he takes them on the larger
tour of the tva in their archives while doing this
big exposition info dump that's just a classic
detective walk and talk which you see in a lot
of movies where they just film exposition scenes
and dynamic ways so there's all these mysteries
that they've just barely scratched the surface
of and he's walking around explaining this and you
have this stuff going on in the background while
they're talking about the case i would be willing
to bet that we don't even scratch the surface of
the tva during season one like we know there's
a season two coming they've already confirmed it
even though they haven't said what the story is
going to be but it's just like gallifrey or the
citadel of ricks and rick and morty there's
just so many stories that you could tell
inside this space it's just set up as this really
complex really interesting area that you've never
seen before in the mcu but if you haven't seen
her this is sophia dimartino this is the actress
that's playing lady loki she was at the london
premiere with tom hiddleston that's the reason
why they're bumping each other like this because
technically there is only one person in this photo
once we get some more footage with her in episodes
in like the next couple of episodes i will do
a larger lady loki video but they've only just
barely begun to tease the character on the series
then you see mobius taking loki on a few tutorial
missions showing him how they use their technology
to time travel around to these different nexus
points or to prevent nexus points from happening
different crime scenes he takes him to the events
of pompeii when the volcano's in the middle
of exploding all the villagers running around in
panic as loki just dances through the streets like
all these people are going to die in a second so
what does it matter then he takes him to a ren
faire we've talked about how king the conqueror is
going to be the main villain of ant-man 3 quantum
mania being played by jonathan majors he's a great
actor so i can't wait to see what he does with the
character but obviously they're getting more into
the quantum realm during that just because they
teased it during ant-man and the wasp then the
avengers just used quantum energy in the quantum
realm to time travel in avengers endgame so a lot
of you have noticed how the tva's time portals and
some of their technology looks like they're using
quantum energy with more sophisticated technology
than the avengers had i did see a few questions
about all this in the comments on my episode 1
video specifically about the timeline of the time
keepers here the reason why they're so advanced
and the reason why they say that their version
of secret wars for instance this multiverse war
happened in the past is because the time keepers
themselves didn't come into existence until the
end of time as you normally think of it the heat
death of this version of the multiverse in this
place the timekeeper citadel was created after
they forged the sacred timeline that's why they
created the time variance authority for so for
them this big secret wars cataclysmic multiverse
event happened in the distant past and when they
plucked this loki out of time and brought him here
this is inside a pocket dimension outside of the
normal flow of space-time but technically for all
the people that work here it's the very distant
future and for the main avengers who are still
alive in present day it hasn't happened yet
because they're all still living in 2023 2024
i think it was just people weren't totally clear
on what point in the timeline this citadel is at
theoretically it's in the distant future even
though it's kind of outside of space time so
it doesn't exist inside the normal timeline the
way you think about it as they continue to jump
around in the timeline to different points i'll
talk about the overall timeline because it will
get crazy during the loki series but there's also
a lot of footage in here from the other future
episodes beyond episode two like you can see loki
and it seems like he's hot on lady loki's trail
you see him all pissed off inside this roxanne
version of walmart called roxcart and it seems
like he's chasing her through one of these tva
portals remember the whole idea is that she's
been trapping tva agents hunting the hunters so
to speak and stealing their time travel technology
like the reset devices but it seems like she also
has some of their portal technology allowing her
to travel anywhere in the multiverse and anywhere
in the timeline she wants that's how she was able
to get the technology from the year 3000 and put
it back in the 1800s in oklahoma then you see loki
cozying up to either his new desk in a cubicle or
it's mobius's desk that he referenced in episode
one like loki talks about burning down the tv i'm
going to burn this place to the ground and he says
good i'll show you to my desk you can start
there that could also be a clue that mobius
senses something isn't quite right with a tva
itself if he's willing to joke so much about
burning this place to the ground as well you also
look at the file that they zoom in on during this
trailer or two this describes the events of the
first thor movie you could probably pick out some
of this text it talks about loki messing with
thor's coronation at the beginning of the movie
allowing the frost giants to enter asgard then
the rest of the plot like luring lafaye his true
father to asgard under the pretense that he could
kill odin but then double-crossing him killing his
father in the process then it mentions how thor
had to destroy the bifrost to save jodenheim from
total destruction and then obviously this scene is
of him revisiting the events of the first avengers
movie again you notice the mirror on the wall here
is the exact same mirror next to the elevator from
the beginning of episode one when they do that
big flashback scene to the events of endgame
so a lot of the episodes will be them revisiting
familiar moments from previous marvel movies from
previous thor movies but right now it's still not
totally clear why lady loki is stealing all these
time reset devices or if she wants to use them
as part of a larger attack on the tva itself
or if it's more about her preventing them from
closing down the new branch timelines the new
nexus points that she's creating like does she
want to create another multiverse secret wars
level conflict but when kevin feige and the writer
said that the loki series is one of the most
important new disney plus series it will have
bigger consequences for the future of the mcu than
some of the other new series is about them messing
with the timeline in the multiverse because it's
pretty clear from all the easter eggs so far just
in the first episode remember we've only had one
episode so far that they intend on building up
to a new avengers secret wars multiverse movie
after doctor strange to multiverse of madness no
idea when that would happen they're just laying
some track work here it's like you see thanos
at the end of the first avengers movie like when
is thanos going to finally assemble the infinity
gauntlet well it took 10 years for that to happen
but part of what they're teasing with this
big multiverse war is also kind of meant to
be a teaser for doctor strange too multiverse of
madness that movie is kind of a smaller avengers
movie in that multiple avengers will appear in it
and kevin feige already confirmed that alternate
versions of avengers from other universes would
appear in it he didn't say which one so you can
theory craft about that but think of that as sort
of a prequel like an appetizer for a full-blown
secret wars movie down the road even though
doctor strange too sounds like it is going to be
insane but the whole idea of them teasing this
big multiverse war is that by the time they're
ready to do it in the avengers movies is that
we'll have a lot of x-men characters by that
time fantastic four the new supernatural based
characters like blade and the mcu so that's how
you explain bringing back a version of robert
downey jr is alternate universe iron man that
didn't die a version of hugh jackman coming back
as old man logan wolverine from the fox movies
like if you thought avengers endgame had a lot of
fan service in it just you wait for secret wars i
will do a separate bigger secret wars video later
this week i was already going to do a kang the
conquer video so i might just do those as a single
giant video because the loki series was teasing
king the conqueror using secret wars so it's kind
of like they're implying that he plays a huge role
in that multiversal war it does make sense some of
those easter eggs sounded similar to the events of
kang war as well which is a more recent story kang
war was kind of like a time travel based version
of avengers infinity war and avengers end game
where you have multiple versions of kang teaming
up from across his timeline to fight the new
avengers team which coincidentally featured some
of the new characters that they've introduced so
far like the new version of falcon captain america
but as you can see the loki series just part
of the story is them going around after these
variant loki's the real overarching story is
the story of this other alternate loki like
lady loki we believe it is i know there are a
lot of people wondering if there's going to be
some dark twist with mobius's character too but i
think the idea is that he's one of the good guys
inside this really shady organization of the tva
and in solving the mystery of lady loki and what
she's doing mobius and loki together will also
uncover larger problems inside the tva itself in
other early theory i think that'll play into the
idea of them seeding king the conqueror into the
background of the mcu before we see him full blown
show up on screen in ant-man 3. but everybody post
all your theories in the comments below my full
episode 2 video will post next wednesday just
like normal congratulations bob jens you're
the giveaway winner from my last big marvel
video please email me on the about page of my
channel so i can get your contact details everyone
click here for my full loki episode 1 video and
click here for my thor 4 love and thunder first
look teaser video thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!